لكن منذ ان تولى ريشي سوناك رئاسه الحكومه
في اكتوبر الماضي طبعا خلفان الاستراس وجد
نفسه في الداوننج ستريت امام تحديات حمل
بعضها التراث التي اتهمها بارتكاب اخطاء
جسيمه لكن هل سنه قادر على معالجه الفوضى
التي خلفتها تراسب ما يرى سوناك تعهد
بقيادته حكومه قائمه على النزاهه والمهنيه
والمسؤوليه حسبه قوله ولكن في اقل من
ثلاثه اشهر وجد ان الطريق الذي مهده للنصر
بدا يضيق وفقا لصحيفه الجارديان الصحيفه
البريطانيه قالت ان القرارات المعيبه التي
اتخذتها تراس وحتى من قبلها بوريس جونسون
ما زال تطارد حكومه سوناك وتحديدا حزب
المحافظين الحاكم فلا توجد رؤيه اقتصاديه
واضحه في الافق حتى الان ناهيك عن تكاليف
المعيشه المستمره في الارتفاع وما صاحبها
من اضرابات عماليه واسعه وخلال فتره وجيزه
خسر سوناك بالفعل وزيراين قبل ويليام سان
الذي اتهم بالتنمر على موظفي الخدمه
المدنيه واخيرا رئيس حزب المحافظين الوزير
نادين زهاوي بسبب فضيحه ضريبيه تحديات
تضعه امام متاعب يتعين عليه تجاوزها سريعا
اذا ما اراد لحكومته الا تجدد نفس مصير
تراس وجونسون